as russia's war on ukraine enters its
fourth month president zielenski has
dismissed the idea that ukraine should
give up some land in order to make peace
this morning we have a first-hand look
at what ukrainian troops are facing near
the front lines cbs news mts tayab and
his crew came dangerously close to
russia's relentless attacks on ukrainian
villages mts shows us what happened
deep in the ukrainian countryside there
are only a handful of farmhouses and
fields here but for weeks russia has
been targeting this village relentlessly
it's here we meet major sergey he and
his soldiers have been defending this
area for weeks but have recently changed
tactics i just want to be clear this is
now an offensive you're targeting yeah
we are targeting every day because we
exactly we need to do this but russian
forces whose positions are just two
miles from here aren't backing down
[Applause]
we just had some incoming
russian shelling
we're just on our way
to find a shelter
in this disused farmhouse
the closest place to take cover is under
a tree
as the strikes intensify
[Applause]
and the shelling gets closer and closer
that was some pretty serious incoming
from the russian side
this was an area they occupied up until
six weeks ago
and they really want it back
getting closer
a russian drone is spotted circling
above it's now or never go go go go go
so we start sprinting
and are led down some stairs into a
nearby root cellar where ukrainian
forces have been taking refuge for weeks
that's more incoming
from the russian side we've really just
been
shelling this area
pretty frequently
the strikes are now just 50 yards away
with us is oxana kosovenko is this
normal for this area
by any measure this is not normal she
says the russians are giving us a hard
time but we can tell they're getting
weaker
after several more strikes were given
the order to make a run for it through
fields of wheat which are now a front
line
and back to our vehicles then drive as
quickly as we can towards safety
for cbs mornings i'm interested on the
curson front lines
harolding
we're happy to say that mts and his crew
are okay but it just shows you how
dangerous it can be bringing the story
to you well it's moved from the top
story the war has not ended there they
continue to fight exactly